about what can we do
by adding randomization so we were
trying to talk about like very basic
deterministic algorithms like and also
runtime complexities
by using those basic approaches
and now let's consider a setting that is
closer to reinforcement learning
so this is a notion called the
generative model
introduced by kakadi i think in his
doctoral thesis so the general model is
like a simulator
let's say that we want to solve this
markov decision problem
but the only thing we have is this
generative model
so we can query so we can ask this
general model
to give us a simple transition
from a specified state action pair sna
so we choose an sna and the generated
model
draw a random sample according to the
true law of transition and give us a
sample
okay so that's the setting of generative
model
so if we have such a way to draw samples
we want to know if we could
develop randomized algorithms and if
randomized algorithms help
at all and further we
are interested into in this theoretical
question
which is say that we don't know the
mdp instance we only have a generative
model
then how many samples would be
sufficient
to obtain an absolute optimal policy
with high probability and how to
construct algorithms
with provable sample complexity upper
bounds
and a related question is how many
samples are necessary
is there an information diagram limit to
learn an absolute optimal policy
with high fidelity from agency model so
this is known as the
pac sample complexity we want to
understand sharply
what is the number of queries
that is necessary and sufficient for
computing an absolute optimal policy
with probability y minus delta
okay and this is where i need my pad
okay
okay i hope this still works can you see
the whiteboard
yes okay perfect
so now let's make value equation
randomized
okay so say that we start with an
arbitrary v0
okay and we are going to draw samples
for each state an action pair
we are going to draw in samples
from the generative model
okay
and then we can compute easily
the empirical transition law
maggie uh can you completely turn down
the volume on the tablet
on the ipad
just turn like uh
probably there is a volume control
somewhere and you can just
completely turn off the volume because
there is a little echo
it's probably not as bad as my thing was
but
did you i can't
okay fine
we can't hear you
i don't know okay can you hear me
yes okay so we have n samples
from the transition law conditional
state
and given as an a and we compute the
empirical
transition distribution from the n
samples
okay so we do that for every state in
action
and now given
v k which is the current
value estimator okay
we try to analyze
the approximation error due to the fact
that we're using samples
okay
okay and by the way we we need let's say
that we we use
fresh samples
for each value equation okay
and notice that our value functions are
always bounded by
virtue of the discount factor
so we can show that this error
is going to be bounded was pretty good
probability
so we want this inequality this error
bound to hold for os and a
that's why we take an additional union
bound and have this i say term in the
log
and this will happen with probability y
minus theta
okay so given this
we are going to use
the pk hat the empirical transition
we obtained from these new samples to
get
an empirical version of the bellman
operator
okay so the next step is we're going to
apply the empirical bellman equator
to obtain the next value estimator
so we can analyze that pretty easily
we are going to use a basic
triangle inequality
so we can take this error term
out
okay
then we can see that every time we're
using an empirical transition
model we are approximately
having a strictly contractive
iteration
and we have some estimation error which
could be bounded from this concentration
inequality
so i'm going to just call it epsilon k
okay so we're iterating this process
and finally one can show that
so we choose to iterate it for about
this many times
then we can show that we can show our
final upper final iron bound for this
battery equation
so in this analysis we we need to make
sure
things are correct for example we are
using
fresh new samples
for every single value equation
so that this error recursion
could hold with high probability and
there's no dependence between iterations
and finally we need all the
concentration to hold our crowd
situation so we need an additional union
across situations anyway
so putting everything together
and we need to also choose the right
choice of delta and the right choice
okay and finally
to get this final value
to be close to the optimal value
within an error epsilon the sample size
we need
in this case is going to be
and uh some log terms which
i don't bother to compute oh
all right so this sample size and this
for every state action pairs we need to
multiply it
by s and a
okay so this is the number of samples we
need
from this generation model to get an
absolute optimal value
by using empirical value equation so if
we want to get an absolute optimal
policy
actually we will need even more accurate
value functions so to get
epsilon optimal pi
the sample complexity turns out to be
this
and a bunch of terms
okay so so what do we learn from here
so apparently randomization does help so
we were talking about deterministic
algorithms and
many algorithms have super linear
runtime
but now if we use randomization
it's actually possible to get sample
complexity
to be linear with respect to s and
a and
if we try to make the algorithm update
smart in a smart way
it turns out that we can actually make
the sample complexity to be equal
to time complexity
okay so we can get one
time update per sample
but however we can if we try to look at
analysis so analysis
turns out to be pretty simple but we
don't really like
what happens here
okay so this is 1 minus gamma to
the power of 7 which is a big number
so what's happening is the analysis we
just
have here is okay but it's not
good enough so it's not good enough in
several different ways
so first the algorithm itself is not the
best algorithm
we can see that the algorithm takes
fresh new samples per each update
to make sure to make the analysis simple
but how do we make the surgeon drop the
the powers on your one minus gamma are
not
readable by people there are several
questions about what are the powers on
one minus gamma
seven oh
and in the expression at the bottom of
the page is five
thanks okay yeah thank you for the
question
okay so basically we lose some factor by
grounding an absolute approximate value
to an approximate policy
so the power releases is raised from
five to seven
okay so those powers are not good
because first
the algorithm is drawing
fresh samples per
iteration
and a lot of we don't really need so
many samples
per equation if we have to
throw them away immediately so we're not
utilizing samples
in a very good way another problem with
analysis is when we try to analyze this
error recursion
if we just analyze the error recursion
in the l infinity norm
so this epsilon k just becomes a worst
case upper bound
and then what happens is we're just
being too pessimistic
in every single error bound what
was really happening is it's possible
that the accumulation of errors
throughout value equation somehow have
its own
statistical property so the error
actually doesn't accumulate
so fast okay
so um i'm not going to talk about how to
improve this to get a final result
because that's going to take
hours but basically it's possible to use
samples in a way that's smarter
and also it's possible to do the
analysis better
if we really try to delve into the
newest structure
and how the noise accumulates in the in
this as in
in the computational process of the
estimator
okay
so i'm going to go back to my slides
this
okay so basically
one can do one can make value equation
work even with only with samples from
magento model
and if we try to be careful as analysis
with the algorithm is possible to
accelerate it
okay
so next instead of doing
value equation one can try to
do q equation which has a number of
advantages so
q function can be viewed as a value for
a value function for state action pairs
so we'll associate each as an a with a
value
and that then we get q function so
we can write down bellman equation
equivalently in the space of q functions
okay and we might we can also have a
bellman operator for q functions
which we call the f and
it's pretty straightforward to see that
bellman operator
in q functions works very similarly
as if it is bellman operator in value
functions
and the q equation has similar
convergence properties as a value
equation
okay but however there is a very nice
property about
q function what's happening is if we
look at
the bellman operator in q functions it
takes the form
of an expectation
so that makes it possible to
solve this fixed point equation by using
stochastic approximation
so that gives rises to the q learning
algorithm
which is nothing but
a variant of stochastic approximation
for solving the belmont equation in the
space of q
functions and it allows us to get an
unbiased estimator
of the bellman operator applied to q
functions
from a single state action state
transitions
okay so by using analysis for stochastic
approximation for
root funding one can show almost sure
convergence
of q learning algorithms under some
proper assumptions that
the data generating process has to be
ergodic and the visit
of the say action pair is sufficiently
open
okay so there's a much richer story of q
learning if we
talk about summer complexity and regret
analysis
but that's not that will be that will be
a topic of future talks
in the program
okay so finally we can also use
randomized algorithms to solve
the linear program of the belm equation
one particular thing to notice is
the linear program of the belmont
equation has a primal form
in the space of value functions and the
dual form
in the space of augmented measures
so it actually is also equivalent to a
saddle point
in which we have a nice strong duality
between the optimal value function
and the optimal stationary occupancy
measure under the optional policy
mendi sorry ambuj again i think the
slide issue of them not advancing has
happened
okay let me again it again
can you see it yeah now i see a slide
with title from lp to bellman satellite
that's right i think i should update my
zoom
okay so the
bellman equation corresponds to linear
programs which corresponds to a nice
minimax
problem in the space of value function
and opposite measures
so it turns out that one can use
approximate
lp methods for solving bellman equations
for this
like one can try to do constraint
sampling to solve large-scale
linear program which in the language of
reinforcement learning
would mean that we simply sample
transitions from a subset
of state action pairs which
would mean that we sample a few rows
from the collection of linear
constraints
another approach is we can directly try
to solve the minimax problem
by doing some form of primordial mirror
descent
so basically to do descent in the valley
space
and ascent in the open measures
and there are several works along this
line
okay so finally
um we want to think about the question
so is there an information through the
lower bound
so how many samples are at least
needed to get
a good estimate of the near optimal
policy
so there was a very nice lower bound
result
proved by azar and a few others
in 2013. so they constructed
an mdp instance such that
any algorithm no matter how smart the
algorithm is
has to make so many queries
to the general model in order to
compute an absolute optimum policy with
probability two-thirds
okay so let's look at this lower bound
so
this lower bound is linear to the number
of states
times number of actions which is what we
expect
from the earlier analysis from fitted
value equation and now if we look at the
power
in terms of the power of 1 minus gamma
it's a power of 3.
so it's much smaller than our previous
analysis
okay so i already plan to actually give
a sketch of the proof and i think my my
equipment is not functioning
optimally today so i'll skip that so
basically the idea of the proof
is to construct a particular instance
such that finding a near optimal policy
to that mdp
would require
testing a particular bernoulli variable
and because the incense is constructed
in a particular way that there are
many different potential hypotheses for
example there are
s times a number of choices for the
bernoulli variables
to have a slightly higher
probability p than all the other
variables and then
any algorithm has to sample all of the
state action pairs
for enough times in order to tell
which of the state action pair has
corresponds to a bernoulli variable
which is slightly different
from all the others okay so that's a
very cute proof
but i'm not going to do that today okay
so finally my last slide so
this is my current knowledge about the
upper and lower bounds
for planning mdp under a generative
model
so the lower bound is the one i just
described to you so
one could construct a particular problem
to show that
it's fundamentally about hypothesis
testing and estimation
and the sample complexity lower bound is
this
and it turned out that there actually
are algorithms that could nearly achieve
this lower bound
so one algorithm is actually an improved
version of empirical value equation
so like i have described so the the
simple value iteration i described was
inefficient because
we are taking new samples per equation
and we are throwing them
away for simplicity of analysis but if
we care
for doing a bit more analysis we could
actually
do variance reduction and show that the
algorithm
actually concentrates much faster than
we expect
so it's possible that a formal value
iteration
achieves the lower bound and another
recent result
is one actually shows that
it's actually possible to achieve this
lower bound by simply
estimating an empirical transition
matrix
from data and then
just use it to get a plug-in estimator
so that's a even shorter answer and a
very elegant method
so in short basically now we know
sharply what is the theoretical limit
and what's achievable for planning in
mdp
under general model and upper and lower
bounds
are nearly matched so that's it for my
part
thank you very much someone asked what
what's the reference that you refer to
as
jin and sid for 2020
uh i think that's uh iron c4's recent
sml paper so one can find that on
sml 2020. i think it's called like
solving mdps using stochastic mirror
descent
but i don't know whether it's on archive
yet or not but it's already published by
xml
okay thanks
okay thank you
right um
let me see i need to share my screen
here
thanks maggie uh
all right
good uh wow my screen
looks completely distorted is it
the same for you guys or
it looks fine on our end okay okay
i just had to uh yeah i'm connecting
these two computers and one of the
computers so that
there's different proportions but uh now
it looks good
on my computer too um
okay um so in this last part uh
of the morning uh i'm going to talk
about
how to scale up things uh
and mainly started to mention a few
things like
approximately in air programming and
whatnot
so this is really important oh by the
way uh
no one really asked the question uh why
are we doing all of this
uh i guess
uh there is reason uh you want to use
planning methods
uh with smaller business first man
learning you are learning a model
and then you need to find out what an
optimal action is
or given tomorrow so that's one reason
sometimes
uh you just build a simulator and then
you believe that
the stimulator is pretty close to your
system and you just want to
know how well you could do and
what action should be taken so there
these are the reasons uh
many times anyways what happens is that
well okay uh what happens is that
uh these mdps are really really large
and so the lower bonds that might be
mentioned show us that
well if you have a big mdp that means
that you have
a large number of states and here i'm
abusing notation by not
denoting the coordinate of the state
space differently i'm using the same
letter for the number of states as
this uh the set of states uh apologies
for that but i just want to
minimize clutter same with action so if
you have
either large state or action spaces uh
or horizon or what not then it seems
that you're toast
with these methods that try to compute
an optimal policy because of the lower
bonds so so this is this is an actual
barrier right so if you're demanding
that you have a mat
uh a planning algorithm that takes these
inputs and
our interacts with the simulator and in
all cases
is able to you know produce correct
answer
then you're going to see these lower
bounds
and kicking in and which means that
it's not that we are lame and we can't
find
good arguments that would solve these
problems fast but
these problems can just be really hard
okay so maybe you need to look at every
possible state in action
it's it's not hard to imagine uh that
this should happen
in the lack of extra structure for
example
the question is what can we do because
uh
uh in most interesting examples uh
the state space tends to have a factor
structure with d factor so that could be
the dimension into the state space
and the d can be really hard so then uh
really large
so the number of states could be really
large or
you know you could even consider
continuous state spaces like uh the
hypercube
and uh so the state space in all these
cases
really really large it's guessed
exponentially uh
is the dimension uh and so that
led to people uh calling the phenomenon
and that the arguments the
the vanilla organisms break down as the
curse of dimensionality
um but just because we see these
barriers we never stop
uh we won't stop uh but instead
uh what we need to do is that we need to
change the problem right so maybe uh
the original problem setting was uh
not the the problem setting that uh
we really need and uh
maybe we can just change it a little bit
and then we can solve some variation of
the problem
uh in which case we may be able to
overcome
this uh computation or query complexity
barrier so here i'm going to talk about
uh three ideas the idea of
localizing planning so i call this local
planning
so previously we're talking about that
you need to calculate the
policy that is basically a big table of
which stay at which state what action to
take
uh and you can imagine if you have many
states than even filling out a table
like that isn't is not feasible
but for example if you're in model-based
rl
you are at a state when you're trying to
use your model
uh that you learn in some way and you
just need to figure out what
action to take it there um so that's
that's local planning
so that that's the first um
thing that i'm going to talk about and
then there are two other things
extra hints a very functional
approximation in policy search
or assuming uh extra structure
so for for this latter i'm not going to
talk much about it
that is uh a lot there would be a lot to
talk about it
i'm just going to illustrate it by
an example which is quite popular this
day since been popular
uh forever so this is the case when you
have
maybe uh vector valued
states uh so the state space
is r to the power of d let's say
and the action space is is also
uh are you grading space r to the value
of i don't know k
or what not and the state of all is
according to this
uh this dynamics here so the next state
is
you know matrix times the previous state
plus
matrix times the action taken and
some noise on the top so this is called
the linear dynamics
it's linear both in states and both in
the actions
and the noise could be just iid gaussian
noise
and the reward could be very nice
uh like the negative
of the quadratic form online state with
a positive definite matrix q
and the same with the actions with a
positive definite matrix
are uh so this leads to uh
this cluster problems called the iqr
problems and they have such beautiful
properties that
it becomes uh feasible and tractable
uh to find an optimal policy as a
function of
uh just these uh these matrices a b
and and q one are right so here
everything that you need to know about a
system is is just summarized by these
four matrices so the planning problem
becomes how to use these uh
four matrices to come up with an action
that uh
an optimal policy would take um
all right so that was just to illustrate
that you could have some extra structure
that helps you deal with
uh really large state uh
and action spaces and
uh so let's return to the uh other two
points
uh so local planning so let's start with
that
so what is first first of all what is
local planning
um by the way is the
sound and everything's fine i hope that
it improved
um so in local planning as i alluded to
uh your input is is
a little bit different than as usual so
you you're given an initial state
and and you have maybe a simulator
access
to to the mdp
that mandy was also talking about and
and the output uh that we require the
planner to produce
is just an action okay that uh
you should imagine that uh this process
is repeated
so as state is inputted to the planner
the planner does some computation access
the
mdp a few times it produces an action
and then this is repeated for the next
state and the next day the next day you
could do this online
and if you do this online this results
in a policy
so so a planner that does this
local planning implements a policy maybe
maybe it's a stochastic policy uh
because
uh i mean the simulator is randomized in
china so the action is going to be
random so
we can uh collect uh
uh or summarize the distribution of this
action given the the initial state
and and that becomes a policy and
uh so here the job of the planner
is to come up with a procedure that
produces actions from
an underlying perhaps implicit
probability distribution
pie such that the induced policy
is going to be near optimal up to a
level of
data all right so that's that's the goal
so the idea here was that we don't need
to fill out
a big table of like what these
probabilities are or
how to choose and every given state uh
the action but we can do this
calculation on demand
either decided to go to sleep ah let me
see whether i can give it some
boost all right i just need to do this
time to time
uh just touch this computer um
okay um so so this is the goal
um and
uh so we are amortizing computation
and so you can save a lot in this way
so for every state we can query the mdp
we can uh perform some computation to
produce the action
uh all together if you have many states
then
all together you may be doing you know
infinite amount of computation after
visiting infinitely many states so
here computation is uh budgeted in a
different way
per state manner so this problem
may be easier so maybe this way we can
overcome this challenge that
uh that is posed by the lower bonds that
would tell us that
you need to depend on the coordinate of
the state space and lo and behold
that's true and the idea is actually
quite simple so recall
the notion of effective horizon
so when we're doing planning if if we
are
uh if we want to produce that optimal
policy then we can cut the trajectories
at at maybe that or that
over to uh uh
level uh effective horizon level which
would be
uh just uh is log one over
epsilon one minus gamma divided by
one minus sorry that's that's a data
divided by one minus gamma and i use
this with data
equals uh i don't know the time equals
uh
that over two uh because if you're
cutting the trajectories then
uh like you don't like infinite
trajectories because that would mean
infinitely many access to the mdps and
infinitely lengthy computations
but you can think about cutting
trajectories after this many steps
and then build a tree so you're given
this initial state as not
and let's say you have just two actions
you take action one and you take action
two
and then you sample from the dynamics a
few nests next states
so these are the next states and you're
gonna sample
m next states
and then you continue for each of the
state encountered
you take uh first action you take the
second action
for each of the actions thing uh again
uh
sample a few next states let's say m of
them
and you do this uh tree building
for the depths of h of uh delta prime
okay uh
and so the question is
uh okay what does this uh give us
uh well um what you can do is that you
can
view this as a way of uh
you know approximating the original mdp
uh in the original mdp if it was a
finite horizon mdp and these were the
actual next days and there would be no
other next state
then you could just do a backwards
calculation
from the leaves uh and you would just
you know
like some of the rewards uh
and uh so that would give you a value at
an action
do it for both actions take a max
sum up the values again so this results
in the value of this state
uh do this for all the other states uh
take the average of them so not summing
but
by taking the average of them
and then the average is assigned to
to the action and then do it for both
actions
take the max and so forth so you can do
this backwards calculation
and if you get to the root and you see
that you know one action
has a higher assigned value to it based
on this calculation
than the other action um then you would
just choose that action
and the only question is uh is this
going to be a faithful
representation of the full mvp
how big should bm
um to get a reasonable estimate
uh for the values here and
in order to do this calculation i'm not
going to do it
but just to to note that you know
averages concentrate pretty fast
and uh here the idea is that
uh we need to calculate you know these
expected values
uh based on next distributions uh
and and we just sample a few next states
uh
but we are using this in a lot of uh
calculations but
only uh finitely many calculations
because we have a finite horizon
so this tree could be big right so it's
gonna be at least two to the age
uh of that size um
but um we also know that we can use unit
bounds right
so if we want that all the averages that
we calculate with high probability
represent the true averages
we can use union bounds and we don't
need to use too many union bonds we
need to use roughly these many union
bonds that those
go into the log when they go into the
log
then h becomes uh
so this m which roughly should be the
log
of the number of different cases that we
need to consider to
control for error probabilities in all
those cases so that's what the union
bond is doing
then the m that you need to take is is
going to be linear
in in the horizon i apologize for
uh the background noise uh out of my
control
um all right java
just to make sure people don't think
they're on a slide that's behind like
could you maybe just
oh okay so right now what i see is a
right panel that says afterlife
uh yeah yeah it's it's fine uh i guess
uh i made a mistake that i was pointing
a lot
uh and and the pointer is not shown but
basically i was
explaining backwards calculations on the
tree
and uh then then i i just added this
little calculation here is the
bond so i hope that that
yeah i think
all right so
based on this uh if you do the
cooperation uh
then you can prove this theorem and this
is from a paper by
current sponsor and uh eng from around
2000
uh and this is called the sparse
trajectory method
and this shows that uh
this uh many queries uh
a is the number of actions h is is is
basically
uh one over from minus gamma uh
so a times age divided by data that is
the required precision to the power of
age so that's kind of the size of the
tree that you're building
so these these many queries are
sufficient
to get uh data optimal actions
uh with high probability
and they also prove a lower bond that uh
without making any further assumptions
about the environment the mdp
are changing the problem uh they show
that
the exponential dependence on the
horizon which
looks really unfortunate is unavoidable
so at least due to the age queries and
as i say obviously there is a
gap between the lower bond and upper
bounds and it would be interesting to
to see how to to fill that gap but uh
but this is what we know so far uh but
the important thing here to note
is that by changing the problem to local
planning
we manage to avoid dependence on
asks so there is no dependence
on s and then you can have variations
you can do this for palm dps i won't go
into the details
uh in palm dps you would have these
uh deterministic policies that take past
observations
in this case the trees become extremely
sparse uh
only one next state but you're gonna
have many trees
uh sampled but it turns so that you
don't need too many
uh too many of these trees so given such
a tree
and the deterministic policy actually
gives
you some value estimate for the policy
and you can just take the averages
across these trees
and you can recycle these trees to avoid
many policies
if you have finitely many of them then
uh the log
number of policies is going to appear in
how many trees you need to take
and uh more generally the vc dimension
or rather
like complexity measure of uh the policy
class is going to
to appear
so this is uh about local planning and
and here i did another note about that
this
has at each afterlife so you may notice
that these trees are uniformly bad
and uh even if the mdp is super nice
these methods are not taking advantage
of uh
this nicer structure uh so remy
and and other people
including myself as well
spent quite a bit of time of of trying
to figure out
how to take uh advantage of the nice
structure of mbps and remy wrote them
very nice training windows wrote a very
nice
monograph that i can only uh warmly
recommend
uh for everyone uh so it's in the
foundations and trans machine learning
so uh so that that much about local
planning uh
the local planning could also be applied
to this uh
situation though uh that mainly
mentioned where you have
continuous mdps uh
and uh and smooth transitions uh
and and and if you do this uh john russ
not is this
uh and i worked a little bit on it uh
you can overcome this
uh one over epsilon to the two n
plus m lower bound uh will be gone and
you can have an arrogatum which is
fully polynomial uh in all the relevant
quantities uh for the same class of mdp
so changing the problem is
is uh if you don't need to solve the the
harder problem why would you
right like it's it's a good idea to
change the problem
all right so what's the other idea so
the other idea
is um is to add
uh extra hints uh and structure
and here one of the things is to uh
to consider value function approximation
the other is is policy search
uh so the last result that i just
mentioned for pump vps
uh was basically a policy search result
it says that
you can uniformly val approximate the
values of any of the policies and
if you are able to then uh search the
space of policies in some
efficient way because maybe the the
policies
policy space is structured in some way
then it would be done
unfortunately life is not so nice
uh actually it happens that
computation uh becomes more often than
not
uh really hard um and
uh so if we uh phrased uh this problem
this policy search problem that
such that given the policy class of uh
let's say
stationary policies
then finding uh the uh the policy that
maximized the value given insurance
state
efficiently is is going to be npr and
this is based on a paper by
uh because losses michael liedman and
barber
uh from uh 12 20. i'm going to add
pointers
uh at the end to the slides and i will
make the slides available uh
so don't worry about those uh for now um
so that's that's one way um
oh sorry so that that's that's bad news
actually right so
uh mp harness tells us that this is
not going to fly unless you add some
extra structure
uh and if you have the extra structure
how are you going to search so my
one idea is to to use some local
structure maybe you have a
parameterization some policies
you have a parameter space and uh this
parameters leave in rd or whatnot
and you go from the parametrization to
uh this parametric policy class that
induces
the occupancy measures and if you take
the inner product with the occupancy
measure
and the reward function then you get the
values
and so you have this composite map where
you go from parameter to policy to
occupancy measure to value right so this
is real valued at the end
uh so you go from rd to r and and this
part is very nice and linear
uh this part is uh this depends on the
transition structure and
somewhat nice so if you had the full
policy class policy iteration what not
it's really nice to to search it
sometimes but not always
and this could be nasty but but together
these two guys could be nasty
so that's that's kind of the issue here
so that's why you could
expect to see uh in the lack of extra
structure some harness results
but okay so let's say we still want to
go with this idea of
low-car search maybe we are just happy
with some
uh some local target and that finds a
local maximum
uh can we even uh calculate
uh the gradient here uh given simulator
access
and uh the answer to this in a nutshell
is that yes we'll be able to do this
and this is based on the so-called score
function method
which has a long history has been
rediscovered i i think a couple of times
and
i believe that maybe uh on the dave and
we're gonna have the talks from the ore
perspective they're going to hear from
peter glean who is one of the original
authors of
of this uh together with ronald williams
uh who discovered it independently uh
for mdp so um so how do we do this
uh so the idea is that you have uh
this derivative that you want to take
and and you can
uh maybe assume some regularity and then
you you hope that you can move this
behind the sum
and then we need to take the call
the derivative here
and and the observation is that if you
take the derivative
of the log
of this probability
then that will become the derivative
of the probability divided by the
probability so if you multiply
with the probability pre-multiply with
the probability
so then these two guys cancel
each other and you just get the
derivative so basically
this derivative here is equal to the
probability
the product of this probability
and the derivative of the log so this is
called the score
function and in some parts of the
literature it's called the score
function method
and uh if you do this you find that
uh okay so we can write this as an
expectation
so the probability distribution p of pi
of h is kept of
the gradient of the log of
the same thing times r of
age okay
so it remains to calculate the
derivative of the log
and uh so here uh the thing to notice
is that uh this probability the
probability of a trajectory the
trajectory has
all these uh states and actions in it uh
is just a long product that that i
mentioned
uh before
and then the product
previous
[Music]
and so so forth and if you take the log
this becomes the log of the sum of the
logs
of the individual terms and the
transition
terms don't have they don't depend on
theta so theta is the parameter of the
policy
so p doesn't depend on theta uh so
that's very handy
and if you're taking the log you're
taking the derivative then you will find
that only the derivatives of these guys
the logs of these guys will show up
and so you can plug that in and that's
that's called the
the score function method reinforce
method instance of course
um so notice what happened here uh
so we constructed an expression for the
gradient
uh which is written in the form of an
expectation
but of course we can't compute these
expectations so we would be using
sampling so we would sample a trajectory
from this policy pi
and calculate this expectation as
a simple average maybe a bunch of
trajectories and then take the sample
average of them which is one of them
and what's true for this uh
estimate this random estimate is that
it's it's going to be unbiased if
uh everything was nicely controlled
uh i mean if these quantities do exist
um
but uh so this is an estimate this is a
random estimate so it's going to have
some variance
uh and lo and behold there are many
other ways of constructing estimates so
people
uh write lots of papers about how to
reduce the variance
there are many many different estimators
these days
another topic that
rapidly gaining attention
is to study uh go back convergence of
these methods
it's really interesting that
many cases we can find the conditions
sufficient conditions
on the policy parametrization
uh such that global convergence holds
and then people are trying to nail this
down
and even uh getting results for the rate
of convergence unfortunately don't have
time to go into this but i will add
pointers to the literature
um and um
so with that i'd like to move on to uh
the last part
i'm already running a little bit late
sorry about that
uh which is to use extra hints uh or
structure
uh in the form of value function
approximation
we're going to see a lot of a functional
approximation
later on but just to give you an
idea so here
the the hint the extra structure that is
assumed
is given as a set of either
state value functions or state action
value functions
and oftentimes they do have a linear
structure
so here phi you can imagine as a big
matrix
s was finite so it has as many rows
as the number of states and uh as many
columns as the number of features
and so the rules of this matrix are the
features and
the assumption is that these features
are available by
by random access to the planner and
again you would consider either
localized or global planning
and the hint is that
this function space captures the belief
that
let's say q star leaves close to this
function space or it
it is actually in this function space uh
if it was
uh about state action pairs if it's
about states then we start leaves
in this function space or a stronger
assumption is that
q of pi for all policies or stationary
uh vertical policy spies
leaves in this function space or or you
could do the same with state
value functions as well and if the
belief is correct then we expect to be
able to replace
uh inner complexity bounds and and query
complexity
and computation complexity bonds the
number of states uh
expected to be replaced by uh the
dimensionality so
it accounts for basically compressing
the states or abstracting the states
uh so you might ask whether this is a
sneak assumption about mvps and uh
yes you could see it that way and we can
even try to make this
expedite and so this became
quite a hot topic recently
so if you uh want to make it explicit
so there is one set of assumptions
um uh that give you some really nice
conditions under which
uh some really nice things happen about
the mdps
and and this goes as follows uh so we're
gonna call
a transition dynamics linear in some
feature maps so
for every state action pad you get a
bunch of features
if there exists a another map
which maps from states to rd
uh such that for all states
actions and next states uh
the probability of uh arriving at the
next state
uh is the inner product
between the feature and
and the value mu takes at a
state s prime this is a factorization
assumption so if this factorization
happens uh to the transition dynamics uh
then a lot of other nice things happen
um
so to make it make things even nicer
we may assume that uh the reward
function is also linear
in the features uh so that means
uh that uh rsa
for every sna is just uh phi
s a times uh i don't know lambda where
lambda is
so there exists some lambda which is
independent of
s and a such that uh this holds for
every s and a and if p and r are both
linear then we call this linear mdps uh
so this was introduced by chi-ching
and uh and others and um
so the claim here uh which is going to
help us a lot
is that if p and r are leaner than for
every policy
every station work of policy q of pi is
also linear
which is easy to see if you think about
what happens with
uh q of pi it's is the fixed point
of the bama operator and in the biome
operator you have
basically the reward
plus gamma times the transitions
and the transitions if you wish you can
write this uh
as this factored for form uh
times uh somehow applying pi to q
uh just introducing your own notation
here
so they're just a state value function
uh
created from the state action uh value
function
q of pi and uh so whenever this
applies you can uh use associativity and
you see that like
okay this this is equal to phi lambda
and this is equal to phi
times mu and some stuff and so the whole
thing
becomes uh can be written as phi times
theta
with with some theta that depends only
on the policy and so this
uh gives you the idea that uh if you
have a linear mdp
then you should be able to work just in
the parameter space
and run a policy iteration algorithm and
lo and behold you can do that
and if you do that then you can get
fully polynomial
argumentums uh under this uh condition
that you have this linear mdps
uh with the truncation and contraction
arguments
you can make this work i'm going to give
pointers again to the literature at the
end
but you might worry about that uh okay
so here basically what we are using is
that q of
pi is in this linear space and this may
be a little bit too strong
so what if q of pi only leaves close to
to this space uh by which i mean
is that if you shift q of pi a little
bit then it becomes an element of this
linear space so this
z is this uh error
uh function and the error
all together is not big it's an epsilon
and you might think that okay
if you have a robust uh target term then
it should be able to survive
uh small changes to problem like this
the question is whether this happens or
not
uh so the surprise comes from these
recent people by
dukako diwan young they basically show
that this
doesn't happen if you want
and a delta optimal action uh
with delta that is proportional to
epsilon
then you can't do that unless
uh you query uh basically you have this
tree and you have to
query exponentially many uh
many states so basically uh you have
this tree and it has
uh two to the age leaves and
and you can hide the reward there and
the features are not going to help you
the jones only needs to show slemo is
used in a
very nice and elegant fashion to to show
this result
so the question is okay
uh where do we go
from here well the lesson here
is that if you demand too much
then uh you're gonna suffer so high
precision
maximization these approximate models is
going to be super expensive
so if you just uh need to solve uh
need to find you know uh
the input to a function which is nearly
linear
uh but the function is over a
a space of many many elements like the
leaves in the previous example of the
tree
it has many many uh elements then the
number of queries that you're gonna need
uh if uh the function
was absolutely close to the linear space
and you require precision of
data is going to be exponential
in d times epsilon over
data
and um
that's that's bad news uh if you want
high precision
but you may also notice that uh so
data is the desired precision if we make
the data a little bit larger
so square root d times epsilon then this
hardness
low and behold goes away uh you can
use many different tools to show this uh
we use the key fair wolf of its
uh lemma in in a recent paper to show
that
this is the case uh so here the lesson
is that
okay maybe don't demand uh such high
precision
and then you'll be fine and you can get
polynomial time results
this still leaves open the question of
what happens if we
make a weaker assumption
just like the optimal action value
function lies
in the function space or close to the
action space we don't quite
know the answer to this uh so with this
i i'd like to conclude team morning and
i apologize for running a little bit
late
um so uh we were talking about
planning uh given a model
which is the problem of finding either a
policy or an action
given an mdp on the different axis
models
uh simulator access uh or
this tubular access if you have finite
mdp
um and different variations of this
planning problem local versus global
for finite mdps i would say that we have
a near complete story
uh of understanding um
at least the discounted corner of mdps
there are
unfinished cases in uh
other challenging versions of mdps
and for large mdps uh the ies we looked
at for
local planning uh computation with hints
uh value function uh hints or policy
search ends
and um and under these conditions
sometimes we can
say positive things but there are many
uh
open problems left and um
another direction that was briefly
mentioned is that you can have just a
favor
and mdp class and of course you could
have a combination of
all of these things and it's it's
fascinating because there's so many
uh open questions still exist today
um so is that i'd like to conclude and
uh
will leave you uh
um to to have lunch uh
i'd be around i'd be on discord and i
guess mangd is also going to be dead
so i recommend that uh we
uh somehow china the questions related
to these stocks to discord
and i i will upload to start with my
slides there
uh just a little bit later uh because i
i have some errands to run now
and so let's have the discussions there
so thank you so much
right
oh okay so there is a question about
what is discord
uh so um
discord is like slack and and that is a
dedicated discord
server
oh that is this okay all right
good um can someone help me to
paste the link here uh anyone who
registered
should have received a
link to the discord server but
if you haven't received it then
maybe we can okay so we have the discord
link here
all right um
okay i also see some i don't know
are there any other burning questions
that i should ask before we go
uh
thanks everyone who were answering the
questions
uh in the background
all right
all right um and see you guys around